hier on n'a pas de camélia jordana
s'était fait insulter aurait mon nom
parce qu'hier j'ai parlé de camélia
jordana c'est vrai que je suis parti
dans les toilettes ensuite encore hier
et même aujourd'hui grâce à camélia
jordana j'adore ça et moi j'étais là je
me vois en toi c'est génial content j'ai
fait de ma famille ça génial effet seul
tendance était par contre j'adore je
suis fou et puis je voudrais remercier
tout trouvé voilà tous mes fans new
skies à chaque fois prennent le temps
vraiment de répondre à chacun des
acteurs
ils sont exceptionnels voilà j'en ai
clan peut-être insularité bleus loïc je
me fais tous les sites et voilà mais il
y en a plein âge hip hop voilà j'adore
aussi j pop us ce qui est exceptionnel
bon il y en a plein et l'aude me voilà
tous voila mais voilà je voulais vous
dire vous embêtez pas avoir ce qu'ils
ont toujours peur que ça me fasse un
malaise serait pas de là mais vous
pouvez leur dire les séries franchement
nous embêtez pas avec ça voilà moi quand
je vois mon nom en top twin je suis pas
permettez moi de vous poser cette
question car il est assez surprenant
parce que ça glisse sur vous comme sur
les plumes d'un canard et c'est quand
même très étonnant parce que malgré tout
je sais que vous êtes un surhomme mais
je vais quand même un homme et ça peut
être du mal à concevoir que ça ne vous
atteignent pas à ce point là je vais
vous dire parce que je vais vous dire je
me suis vous le dire mais il faut pas
essayer d'être les lecteurs il vous
aimons vous sert à rien d'aller leur
part les uns par uns pour qu'ils
essaient de vous aimer c'est leur truc
il aime bien faire ça il existe à
travers ça un jour ça à duda qu'ils
aiment pas le lendemain ce sera
quelqu'un d'autre il faut les laisser
seller qui boit trop ce mot est à la
limite
voilà moi ça me fait rire c'est plutôt
marrer parce que même il ya des haters
qui me font énormément rire qui me font
des vannes tout ça je me dis tiens j'ai
réglé aujourd'hui devait reprendre ce
soir
et moi j'adore quand on vannes 3 soi
même quand on insulte ça ne dérange pas
voilà à part quand ces deux visions mais
si non vraiment c'est assez sympathique
voilà moi ça me fait plutôt rire je vous
dis franchement je le prends bien ça me
fait marrer je vous l'avez vu vous avez
décidé que c'est la règle du jeu et
sabra bravo avant il ya eu un truc pour
la qui m'avait l'air je vous dis la
vérité
il ya eu un tweet qui m'avait l'air
vraiment de toute l'histoire c'est quand
j'avais mixité anniversaire de mon fils
est un abruti qui a dit j'espère qu'il
va passer un mauvais anniversaire ça se
serait passé un abruti vous inquiétez
pas je les localiser je vais le
retrouver
c'est la gueule voilà